Reading and listening are both
powerful ways to learn a language.
They are also powerful goals
of learning a language.
We want to read, we want
to understand what we hear.
We want to understand movies.
And yet the fact of reading in
the language and listening in the
language helps us learn the language.
But then the question always comes up,
should we read first or listen first?
Or people say, I don't
understand anything.
How can I listen?
I don't know any words.
How can I read?
How do I get started?
So I want to talk today about
the strategies that I use.
For reading and listening and when
it's important to read first, when
it's important to listen first.
First of all, reading, and it's
a tremendous cognitive feat for
the brain to be able to read.
So the idea that we can convert
the writing lines on a page
into meaning is pretty amazing.
What's also interesting, and this
was pointed out recently in a
short video that I saw by Andrew
Huberman, but it's something that
I have experienced myself and that
is, when we read, we sub vocalize.
We actually voice what we're reading.
If one were to put an amplifier to
measure the firing of those muscles
in our vocal cords, we'd find that
as we're reading information, we are
actually speaking that information.
That's not the same as speaking.
Speaking means creating sentences,
thoughts, utterances, where we
are drawing on our ability in
the language, our memory of the
language, our model of the language.
That's speaking.
Simply reading out loud or sub
vocalizing actually is not speaking.
But it's a very good way to move you in
the direction of being able to speak.
So if reading is connected to sub
vocalizing, and we also know that
essentially the same parts of the brain
are involved in reading or listening, if
we're going to read and we're going to
sub vocalize, we have to know what those
words or how they are pronounced, to some
extent, even if we pronounce them poorly.
So that would suggest that we
should begin by listening so that
we get a sense of how the words
are pronounced so that we can then
effectively sub vocalize while reading.
In simple terms, I would divide
my sort of strategy or approach to
listening and reading and the order
in which I do them into three stages.
So the absolute beginner stage, call
it A1 to A2 stage, then the sort of
intermediate stage, which is B1 really.
'Cause once you're at B2,
you're kind of launched.
And then once I'm at B2 or
beyond, what is my strategy?
At the very beginning, I look at a
sentence of Finnish, as you will see.
I see words.
If these words are written in the
Latin alphabet or an alphabet that I'm
familiar with, I can kind of pronounce
it, but as you'll see in Finnish,
I can't really pronounce it the way
it's pronounced in Finnish, but I
can kind of make an effort to do so.
So therefore, as a beginner,
I would, first of all, go at
this text in sentence view.
So one sentence at a time, and then
I would listen to that sentence...
and then I would try to read that
sentence ... so the order would be listen
first, then read, but very soon, again,
dealing with one sentence at a time, I
would try to force myself to read first
and then listen, because we can get lazy.
If I listen to it, then I'm not trying
hard enough to vocalize those sounds.
So I would typically say, if I'm doing the
mini stories, maybe after many story two
or three, I would try to make an attempt
at pronouncing the sentence in Finnish
because I can read the Latin alphabet.
Then I would listen to it and
then I would say it again.
And so this is building up my capability
to sub vocalize so that I can read
more and more difficult material.
Remember that all of the skills that
we develop through whatever practices
we engage in, we're gradually building
up our ability in the language.
It's very similar to what happens in AI.
Exposure to a lot of different contexts
it's going to help us almost predict
what's coming at us and being able to
predict is also both in the case of
artificial intelligence and in the case
of learning a language is an important
part of us getting a sense, sort of
a model of what that language is.
So that's at the beginner stage.
One sentence at a time, starting
off listening first, then read,
then listen, then read again.
The next stage, and by the way,
this idea of having a reading and
listening strategy that depends on
the stage you are in the language, I
think is a good thing to try to do.
But the point there is that whether
we're reading or listening, we are
in fact kind of doing the same thing.
And the two learning activities
and the two goals of our learning
very much work hand in hand.
If we look now at the intermediate stage,
obviously it's easier to listen first.
I get up in the morning, the easiest thing
for me to do is to listen to something.
So I'll go grab a podcast,
let's say in Farsi.
While I'm listening to that, there
is quite a bit there that I didn't
understand or that I'm kind of
familiar with the words, but I'm
not entirely sure what they mean.
So that then triggers my curiosity
to go and read that transcript,
which I can now do automatically
in LingQ using our Whisper AI.
So in that situation where I'm B1 and
a half in Persian, I tend to listen
and then later on, I'll go in and read.
Also, this issue of intensive
reading versus extensive reading.
Intensive reading, you're looking
up every word, you're going
over the sentence a few times.
Extensive reading, you're just reading.
And the same applies to listening.
I have found that at the beginning stage
for me, it's not possible to just, you
know, go straight into extensive reading,
not looking anything up, just listening.
I can't do it.
I have to have a certain level
of vocabulary, a certain level of
familiarity to be able to move to
more extensive reading and listening,
no longer in sentence mode perhaps,
certainly not repeating what I'm
reading or listening, and maybe I don't
even have to read what I listen to.
I can read over here and listen over
here, and all the while I'm building
up my capability in the language.
So, the further we are along in the
language, the more we have a tendency
to not repeat, to not go back and
it's better for us not to repeat.
I just wanted to talk a little bit
about, because the question always comes
up, do you listen first or read first?
And I think this very much depends on
your level in the language, where you
are in the language, what you like to do.
It's in your interest, I think, to develop
a taste for both listening and reading,
because the greater the variety of paths,
of formats that we use, the better for us.
Makes things more interesting, and
I think we learn better that way.